[MUSIC]
Think for a moment about a hot dog.
What comes to mind?
Let me be the first to tell you that
I think the concept of a hot dog is
absolutely revolting.
Pink rubbery mystery meat in a long
tube-like shape that makes you wonder,
is it really food that most of
us drench in ketchup, mustard,
sometimes relish to mask
the strange salt-laden flavor?
But believe it or not, I love hot dogs.
Eating a hot dog pulls at my heartstrings.
To eat a hot dog is to hang out
with my family at a baseball game.
It's a barbecue with
friends in the backyard.
And here in the US, it's celebrating
American independence on the 4th of July.
When I think of a hot dog,
I think of family,
I think of friends, I think of fun.
My name is Adrian Kerester,
and I love meat.
But I also care deeply about our planet,
and
I'm concerned about the meat
industry's impact on our environment.
After all, the meat industry is
the leading cause of deforestation,
of water contamination, of air pollution,
and of soil biodiversity loss.
It is also responsible for more than
one-fifth of global greenhouse gas
emissions, which is more than
all of transportation combined.
Because of this, I have tried to
cut me out of my diet not once,
but five times, and
I have failed every time.
I've heard countless
stories of individuals who,
after watching one of the many
harrowing documentaries about
the meat industry,
have cut meat entirely out of their diet,
exclaiming triumphantly, and
then I never ate meat ever again.
Was something wrong with me?
I turn to you, my Stanford classmates,
for some help answering this question.
Over 50% of you, half of this room,
have tried to cut meat out of
your diet before, and
only a fraction of you have stuck with it.
I'm not here today to tell you
to cut meat out of your diet.
It's not effective, and
people don't like being told what to do.
I'm here today to give you
the meat-lover's guide to environmentally
conscious eating,
which I will do in two ways.
First, by diagnosing our love for meat,
why is it that we eat meat so much?
And second,
by inspiring individual action,
sharing with you some tips of
ways that we can collectively
reduce our meat consumption and
cut our carbon footprint, and
convincing you that your individual
action does in fact matter.
All right,
let's diagnose our love for meat.
Like a typical consultant, I sent out
a survey, and I crunched the numbers.
Here are the top three reasons
why we love and eat meat.
Reason number one, it's the default.
Over 80% of you shared with me that you
eat meat because it's the default option.
It's easy, it's available, it's what your
friends serve when they host you for
dinner.
It's embedded in your holiday traditions.
It's featured in the entrees at
the restaurants you frequent.
The list goes on.
For me, meat is central to my notion
of what makes a complete meal.
Growing up,
family dinner was a daily sacred ritual.
Every evening around 7:30 PM,
my family of four would
gather around the table to share
a meal and debrief the day.
My memories of these dinners are deeply
defined by my dad's dinner music,
dim lighting, candles, good conversation.
And my mom's absolutely
delicious homemade meals that
were well-rounded and
often followed a simple equation,
a meat-based meal with two sides,
starch and greens.
Today, family dinners
are typically vegetarian, and
my notion of what makes
a meal has evolved.
But I find that I have to work extremely
hard to fight this default bias.
Until we position plant-based
options as the default, and
reposition meat as a secondary, or a side,
or even a specialty option,
meat will always be the go-to.
Reason number two,
it's all about the protein.
Over 70% of you shared with
me that you eat meat because
it's a high protein option,
and you're not wrong.
However, we don't need nearly
as much protein as we think.
In fact, the average American eats
over 100 grams of protein a day,
which is roughly double
the recommended amount.
This fact doesn't shock me.
After all, the diet industry
pours millions of dollars
into convincing us that protein is
the beacon of health and wellness.
But it did make me wonder
what foods could I eat to
get my recommended 50 grams
of protein a day sans meat?
It's actually really quite easy.
For example,
instead of eating two servings of chicken,
one at lunch and one at dinner,
we could eat two eggs at lunch and
spinach feta chickpea salad
with some almonds at dinner.
We don't need to rely on meat
as our main source of protein.
And finally, reason number three.
We still don't really
love the alternatives.
Over 50% of you shared
with me that you eat meat,
not because you love it, but because
the alternatives are too expensive,
too carb heavy, too greasy,
and sometimes just too bland.
So what can we do?
At the beginning of this presentation,
I shared with you that I'd provide
the meat-lover's guide to
environmentally conscious eating.
If you love meat, but you want to
reduce your carbon footprint and
help save our planet, what can you do?
Where can you start?
And does it even matter?
While there is no
one-size-fits-all option,
I want to challenge each of you
to do three things this week,
better meat, in smaller portions,
less frequently.
Why better meat?
It turns out that not all
meat is created equal.
Beef and lamb are significantly more
harmful to the environment than chicken or
turkey.
If you do purchase red meat, look for
options that are certified organic, or
pasture raised to support meat production
systems that don't use environmentally
harmful pesticides that contaminate
our water, or ruin soil biodiversity.
Smaller portions, I challenge all of
you to rethink your notion of what
makes a meal, and try meat as a side or
a topping, instead of a main.
The USDA recommends a serving size of
just three ounces of meat per meal.
Which, to put in context, is about
a third of the size of the chicken
breast that you see typically
at Trader Joe's or Safeway.
If you're out to eat, try splitting
a meat-based entree with a friend,
in addition to a vegetarian,
or a fish entree.
Finally, eat meat less frequently.
The best thing you can do for
the environment and for
your long-term health is to reduce the
number of meals you eat containing meat.
I challenge all of you to pick just one
day each week to dedicate to be meatless.
Meatless Mondays have grown in popularity
across the country, and around the world.
As someone who loves the social and
cultural aspects of eating meat,
I actually don't prescribe to
meatless Mondays on a regular basis.
But I don't cook meat at home anymore.
This shift has allowed me to drastically
reduce my meat consumption from
nearly daily,
to now only a fraction of my meals.
If you take just one thing away from
this presentation, let it be this.
If everyone in the US were to not
eat meat for just one day each week,
it would be the same as not
driving 91 billion miles.
Which, if you do the math,
is basically the same as not driving from
San Francisco all the way to New York and
back 15 million times.
Small changes at scale really
do add up to make a difference.
So I'll leave you with this.
Better meat, in smaller portions,
less frequently.
This is something we can do as
individuals with our families and
role model for our organizations.
Together with these small changes,
we really can make a big difference.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]